so for this next look is inspired by the
Mad Men logo we're going show you how to
get an updated version because you don't
want to slick it down all the way per se
but we're going to give you a little bit
more modern but it's definitely inspired
by Mad Men first you want to start with
wet hair and the Mad Men look is very
straight so I'm going to do a simple
little technique that's called flat
wrapping and you're going to go left to
right switch hands the door drier to go
the opposite way so now that it's almost
all the way dry still a little bit damp
we're not talked about how to get the
perfect part so what makes the madmen
look so special is the very severe side
part so you just want to go like that
pick up what's on one side push it that
way and the other side push it the other
way want to use a significant amount of
gel because want the hairstyle to last
all day again in front to back past the
front get all the way through before you
start to style it this is a look that I
often get requests for the red carpet or
a black-tie event so I send my clients
out on the carpet to award shows a lot a
little bit more of a dress
look and so then I'm just going to start
to mold it into shape the reason why we
use gels because it helps to lock in the
hair style for the whole night so this
is another reason why this part of the
comb is so great you can put the comb in
there and just kind of pull forward and
play around from volume so it's really
up to you as to how much volume you want
in the front you can do a little or none
at all or you can do a lot and there is
the 5-minute madmen perfect red carpet
hair
you